yo what's up everybody prestigio man
Luigi here with another Borderlands the
pre-sequel legendary weapon guy today
I'm gonna be looking at the skull masher
which is a legendary Jacobs sniper rifle
it is one of the only two sniper rifles
that at this time I know of are
confirmed in the game there might be
more but those this in the long nail or
the only two I know of I'm gonna be
showing you how to get it and kind of
what it's like this is gonna be more of
a review video than a guide because
getting it is pretty complicated the
boss that drops it Nell is it's a
difficult process to get the farm to him
and I've already made a video about that
so when I show you the part of now I'm
gonna link you to the actual guide of
how to farm now but and now we move on
so the skull master is a as I said a
legendary Jakob sniper rifle it is a
it's red text is a real head-turner turn
to mush hahaha
so it's not a too like interesting of a
red text in my opinion I had got the
took hope skull masher which i think is
what gives it the 50% melee damage and
possibly the mine is 66 percent weapon
damage I'm not too sure exactly since
I've only gotten one the sniper the
reason it's a legendary I think it's
kind of like the Maggie where you get
six shots or six damages damage
indicators for the price of one bullet
you can see the damage is there it's
twenty three hundred and four times six
and every time I shoot the bullet shoot
the gun it only takes one bullet so I'm
getting six shots every time I shoot
which dut mate let's do a lot of damage
to kill a ton of enemies really fast
especially if you're getting criticals I
think it works really well for Nisha
because it is a Jacob's weapon and
there's a lot of Jacob's build and Nisha
it's I've gotten a non-elemental I've
only seen non elementals so I it maybe
can be an elemental sniper rifle however
I I think it's not gonna be and that
does have some extra bonuses with Nisha
and the all the auto aim skill of Nicias
showdown does really help with this and
getting crits and stuff so I'm gonna
show you the where to find it we can
No and how it does so as I said before
it is dropped by the secret boss Nell I
made a video guide of how to kill now so
you're gonna be so see something on the
screen and you can click that if you
want to see how to get to and kill now
you see right now I'm in the battle with
Nell once you activate his his little
special boss fight I guess I would call
it he sends out a bunch of minions that
you have to kill just kind of like
moonstruck sand scabs and just a bunch
of enemies like that and then once you
kill all those you can fight Nell and
kill him I think he has a pretty good
drop rate since I've only killed him
twice and I got the schoolmaster on the
second kill of him you see that's I
didn't get her the first time since
that's the only time I recorded killing
him but there's the second the second
time I killed him and I got the skill
masher I got a level 50 so I think it's
a pretty great sniper rifle definitely
good to use and so yeah make sure if you
want to see how to farm Nell that you
click that link since this video won't
really show you too much of how to farm
now how to activate them since he's he's
in the regular range which is right next
to surrounding his waist he's in the
abandoned building complex of regolith
range now here I have a little gameplay
of me using the sniper rifle against
high leveled enemies enemies that
leveled to my level on the max level
currently a true vault hunter mode level
50 and it does a pretty good job of
taking them out especially with the
short end cool Venetia has and so I get
a lot of extra damage because it's a
sniper rifle it doesn't have a huge mag
and it's not an elemental so I really do
get a lot of damage with it especially
with that x 6 shots that it gets just
kind of like the Maggie so I would say
this is kind of like the Maggie in
sniper in sniper form since it is a
Jacob's gun it does shoot six shots for
the price of one and it does pull out a
lot of damage so that's gonna be
basically it for the video I hope you
guys have enjoyed make sure to keep
watching my channel for more boring
super sequel content since I will be
doing a lot more legendary guys and a
lot more stuff I hope you guys have
enjoyed this I do a pretty
if you've watched this all the way to
the end and that's about it I'll see you
guys in the next video